maze runner it's a fun adventure
now that i've seen the movie in imax
uh it's the way to see it it's brighter
it's clearer it's more immersive
it's the scope and scale these gigantic
walls
that are trapping these kids in like you
everywhere you look you you see this
kind of world that you're essentially
imprisoned by
it actually works really well in the
imax format just being that kind of big
canvas that we can play on being up
there seeing that much screen real
estate
i personally like that as a filmmaker
myself the idea of settling
in and being quiet you can create energy
in other ways through the frame itself
you can do so much storytelling and so
much kind of feeling and immersion just
with sound and unfortunately you know
imex has really great sound too
i can't believe the first scene with the
doors closing and this monster of a maze
beyond these walls that comes to life
and breathes into this movie
sure about this no it is a sound
experience
it's all about roller coasters ups and
downs and you need to be able to go out
and be quiet for a bit
the doors aren't closing so that when
you go and hit those peaks of
intensity that it means something i've
seen the movie now
in imax it's the way i want bodies to go
see the movie you know it's
it's cool
you